hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
for monday october 18th
2021 what's going on how are ya
how's it going
how's it going everybody i hope you're
having a better day than i am i have a
splitting
headache
jesus christ i got a headache
i've had it for like a day now
or two days or something like that it's
just um
i don't know what it's just this [ __ ]
lingering cold it won't go away i get
tested for covert it's not covered i
don't know what it is but every time i
start to like
get on the other side of it like an
[ __ ] i'll go smoke a cigar
thinking i'm on the other side of it and
then yeah
[ __ ] comes back again
[Laughter]
but i had
i had an amazing time in atlanta even
though i didn't even go out really
really i didn't really even go out i
just [ __ ] stayed in my hotels
and not even because i was quarantining
like a good little liberal wagging my
finger at you guys and your
four-wheelers on your way to your waffle
house
i st i had all this [ __ ] work to do
i have so much [ __ ] work to do
that instrument rating is slipping away
from me i just don't know if i'm gonna
have time to do it because i wrote a
script and people might buy it and i
have to do a rewrite on it and i just
but that was just thinking like you know
what well i gotta do is just [ __ ]
take the written test again and then i
got another two years to do it and i'll
just time it out but until then i'm
still gonna fly three four times a week
doing approaches i'm still gonna look at
[ __ ]
all this [ __ ] my flash cards and all
that stuff so i'll just be ready to go
i'll just be ready to go i'll stay sharp
on that fine tune it i don't know when
the [ __ ] it's gonna happen but
i feel like a [ __ ] loser man but it
is what it is
if i try to do all of this [ __ ]
something's going to suffer and it's
going to be my dad time with my kids and
i'm not doing that because speaking of
that speaking of that one of the best
[ __ ] holidays to be a parent with
little kids is coming up 13 days away
baby halloween
i cannot
[ __ ] wait
you know i think the kids gonna be able
to go out this year you know they're
wearing masks right
it'll be fine
i hope i just remember how excited my
daughter was a couple years ago we got
my uh my wife bought this little like
dinosaur
suit for my son it's [ __ ] the cutest
thing ever the little spikes going down
in the tail and all of that
and he just walks around looking
adorable as hell um
that's gonna be awesome man i'm really
uh
i'm really excited for that and i have
that weekend off and i'm not doing [ __ ]
i'm making pumpkin bread
and i'm hanging with the kids
doing what i'm supposed to do so i don't
lay on a deathbed someday [ __ ]
thinking i blew it
so anyway let's get back to atlanta
what a great city great state great
people and all of that and the universe
has a way of balancing that
if you're gonna go to atlanta and see
all those beautiful people and
eat all that wonderful food and see that
whole nightlife and all that great [ __ ]
that's going on
the universe is like all right well you
got to pay for that i'll be paying for
that
the most hellacious traffic you'll ever
sit in
other than la trying to get from one
side of the 405 to the other around
[ __ ] 4 o'clock
it's actually worse at four than it is
at five because everybody leaves around
3 30 thinking they're getting a jump
and then not
five still sucks but i don't think it
sucks as bad as four it's kind of weird
so
we played uh three different venues me
and dean delray
oh and then i have a couple of friends
that live down there one of them todd
paca
he jumped on uh two of the three nights
hung out every single night
and um
he's a guy uh i started after him in
boston
he's only like a year older than me but
he started like three four years before
me or three years before me i think and
the first time i ever did stand-up
he was uh
i was in that comedy competition find
boston's funniest college student and lo
and behold he was one of the judges
so that was pretty cool we always talk
about that whatever we had a great time
doing what we always do hanging out
laughing busting each other's balls
talking about
our kids and everything so it was great
to see him and then another comic
that i've been friends with forever
vanessa fraction
who's been crushing it in uh atlanta a
lot of people don't know atlanta is like
sort of like a mini hollywood you get
all that tyler perry stuff going on
there they shoot movies there all the
time
obviously the show atlanta is shot there
i believe unless they just take the
exteriors i believe it's all shot there
but um
yeah i've known her for forever and she
she jumped on the last night she
absolutely killed which was great so a
nice wide variety
a bunch of different we had like four
comics on you know the last two shows
that i did which by the way was the
worst traffic that night because the
venue was right next to where the braves
play
their new one that they moved closer to
the people they had to move it closer
to the white people so they wouldn't be
sitting in that [ __ ] traffic
like they literally weren't i thought
they didn't show up because they're like
well the braves are in it every year
i'll wait for the world series
aft having sat in that traffic i will
never trash braves fans for not going to
a i would never go to a game
i would never go to a [ __ ] game
oh my god dude we sat
we sat at a light i swear to god
for about 25 30 minutes
trying to get through it and then the
next light was like another 15 minutes
and the whole time i can see the
baseball stadium and the venue
and nobody's going anywhere and
everybody's getting frustrated and
everybody starts driving like the way
they drove in boston massachusetts back
in the day i don't know if they still
drive that way
i was there for a week this summer they
didn't seem nearly as aggressive as i
remember
but um
yeah there was definitely [ __ ] you
unblocking the intersection because i'm
not waiting another light i'm just not
okay i'm just not i ain't doing it [ __ ]
off man
don't beep at me i got a gun too right
that type of [ __ ]
but was kind of cool though like the the
uh
the nlcs
dodgers versus the braves
was going on
as we were coming in people going and
you could hear the crowd you felt the
excitement and all of that it was really
awesome
and uh had i known it didn't i don't
think it sold out i would have tried to
dip in in between shows i definitely
stood out there to listen to the crowd
when in between shows i just literally
just walk out
the door stick my head out
i felt like i was in uh
you know those old baseball stories
billy crystal's error you know when they
had all three baseball teams were in uh
in new york city and the [ __ ] players
would take the train to the ballpark or
whatever like i felt that's what it felt
like i'm just walking out of my my house
or something and there's a giant
baseball stadium and he had the sound of
the crowd and smelling the food and all
that so it was really uh
really awesome but i will tell you that
[ __ ] traffic
no thank you
no
[ __ ] thank you
i remember that years ago
2017 i did um
i did a movie down there called the
front runner
and i remember one night we were
we wrapped and we got in the van
and i was sitting in the van and for a
half hour i could see my hotel
and i kept asking the driver if i could
just get out and walk
and he said unfortunately i can't
because if you get hit
it you know i'm going to lose my job the
production's going to have to stop and
so i just had to sit in this [ __ ] van
there like it's right there
it's right [ __ ] there
um
but i always once you get where you're
going in atlanta you always always
always have a good time everything in
atlanta is a good time even their titty
bars back in the day when they went
there was more like a party
rather than the creepiness of uh
of uh the other titty bars you know
i don't know that's
every time i go there i think about
doing the rich [ __ ] tour
with the late great charlie murphy rest
his soul and don l rawlings
and that one oh my god honey i gotta i
gotta have dawn ellen one time talk
about all these [ __ ] stories
he got so [ __ ] mad at me
he got so [ __ ] he got mad at me and
charlie did it too it was [ __ ]
hilarious he went on last
and he was just going and going and he
was just feeling it he just kept going
and going we had merch we wanted to sell
the merch and the thing is if you go too
long
you burn out the crowd they're not going
to buy any of these [ __ ] t-shirts
these stupid itchy t-shirts that we made
and he just kept going and going to go
to me and charlie go what the [ __ ] is he
doing
show [ __ ] over a half hour ago he's
still going so we get into the sound
booth
and you know it's all black in the sound
booth he can't see so the guy in the
sound booth turned the light on
and he looked it he saw the light come
on both me and charlie stood there put
her arms up like dude what the [ __ ] and
he just did the big you know with the
hand like get the [ __ ] out of here he
did like another [ __ ] 20 minutes
he got on stage he was so [ __ ] mad
you don't give me the light son
nobody could be like son you know all
this [ __ ] right
i'm sitting there going like donald the
[ __ ]
it's like a [ __ ] three-hour show
we're not led zeppelin we've got we
don't sell these t-shirts we gotta
[ __ ] bring it back with this big
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you fight and then
like
20 minutes later we were in a bar
laughing about it
and that was that tour um we had such a
[ __ ] great time one time darnell
we were in nashville
and we went to this country ass bar and
he [ __ ] went up on stage and did
karaoke
he's got a really good voice and crushed
this country song
[Music]
it's just like i never saw that coming
when this total [ __ ] everybody in
there had cowboy boots on and wranglers
but us and he went up there
he went up there i still remember it he
had a cigarette he grabbed the
microphone and me and charlie were
already laughing and then he just
[ __ ] killed it [ __ ] killed it
god damn it man i miss charlie that was
such a fun tour
just being on that show was so much fun
um
i actually saw donnell uh
that was a couple nights ago
a few weeks ago i don't know what the
[ __ ] it was sunday night chocolate
sundaes
sweating out the name of the show
at the laugh factory i went down the
store and they weren't having a show so
i came back and i i did that one and i
needed to to do a set i forget why i
think i had i had shows or something on
the road so i wanted to
you know shake the rust off on one out
here and uh dude he was up there
murdering and i went up and had to work
my ass off to just have a mediocre set
he had some of the best [ __ ] that he's
i've ever seen him do the best [ __ ] i
should say
so check him out if you get a chance um
look at me spreading the [ __ ] love on
this podcast
giving shouts out to others even despite
the fact that i have a headache
and a little bit of a [ __ ] cold
you know this [ __ ] cold is like some
relative that you know i'm only gonna
stay a couple of days and it's just been
like a month it's just like dude
you know you don't know any chicks in
this town you can [ __ ] sleep on a
couch
[ __ ] out of here so tonight i'm gonna
try to like
i'm gonna try to knock this thing up i'm
gonna try to knock this thing out man
that's what we're trying to do um so
anyway let's talk alcs baby the boston
red sox what the [ __ ] is going on
their bats are on fire [ __ ] grand
slam
in the first inning i of course missed
it because i had shows and i was also
watching the lsu
lsu florida game
which was like madden football
no field goals just touchdown next team
touchdown touchdown touchdown it was
like 42 to 42
with like nine minutes to go
i can't remember the last thing lsu
scored the last touchdown and then
picked uh intercepted the ball
and was able to uh
run out the clock after that it was like
49 42 something crazy like that
uh
and then somebody texts me said dude the
[ __ ] socks that i looked and it was
eight to nothing after two innings
and people were bitching
that the uh
the [ __ ] we playing the astros they were
doing some sneaky [ __ ] that's funny
thing
the astros now have that [ __ ] stink
on them
you know
anything they do now they'll be like oh
they're cheating
they're [ __ ] cheating you know i love
that they're cheating
all these [ __ ] [ __ ] fans you know
they're [ __ ] cheating what about the
steroid era everybody was
you know
what about the fact that we have bottled
water
these corporations don't give a [ __ ] and
they port in the river to the point you
have to buy clean water which isn't
really clean water the ones in the
plastic bottles they sit in [ __ ]
warehouses for years
um
i don't know so somebody bitched about
it
on the red red sox side and then
somebody made a deflategate comment
hey don't get upset
you know don't don't let these don't let
the astros let all the air out of your
ball is what they said which was funny
but i really sat back i was like wow
that is the greatest one of the great
smear campaigns
of all time
the deflategate thing like that was
actually legit that's right up there
with mama cats choked on a chicken boat
from the mamas and the papas everybody
said that when i was growing up
everybody said that and then years later
was like no she had a heart attack
that's what happened
she wasn't [ __ ] eating chicken too
fast and choked on a [ __ ] chicken
bone that's not what happened
[Laughter]
anyway so we will see what happens i
mean uh
that's [ __ ] nuts if the red sox can
get by
the astros
it's great because if we play the
dodgers there's a rematch
right and then the dodgers also have a
chance to go back to back and it's also
boston versus la beat la that's a great
one
or we play the atlanta braves who used
to be
the boston braves and then became the
milwaukee braves and the atlanta braves
and i think there was something else
before that before they were the boston
braves
um
solo say all of that they'll bring up
[ __ ] how babe ruth finished his
career with the [ __ ] braves i think
the boston braves believe it or not
i'm not sure they're gonna bring up all
of that stuff and it's gonna be [ __ ]
wonderful
and if the red sox win the world series
that's number 10 and we are in double
digits
with the championships
you know
which is pretty cool you know for a
little [ __ ] city with four teams
17 nba titles nine world series six
daily cups
six super bowls that's pretty [ __ ]
good
now like everybody says
um sorry
um so anyway this morning we get to the
uh we get to the airport
and there's this poor kid just freaking
out like it's been a while since i've
seen a kid freaking out like this
and then this [ __ ] in a dodgers hat
he must have gone to the game
looks at his girlfriend or his wife and
just goes like
[ __ ] kid better not be [ __ ]
sitting next to me
i just looked at him
i love people that get mad at children
i just don't understand it
i was joking about that on stage you
know when i was a kid i i saw
like men yelled at babies when i was a
kid it was [ __ ] hilarious or yelled
at their wife guys shut that [ __ ] kid
[Laughter]
just don't understand it
so this kid was was [ __ ] this kid
went in
was having a temper tantrum
and uh
yeah everybody was sitting there going
like oh my god this is going to be a
loud ass flight but uh but also kind of
you know laughing like you know that's
what happens when you fly there'll be a
kid and a kid's gonna freak out it
happens and at the end of the day it's a
kid
so why would you get mad
at a kid
right
so um
i don't know i just sort of stared at
the guy i was i was like what am i why
am i staring at this guy this guy's half
my [ __ ] head you could throw me
down to [ __ ] baggage claim
maybe because i had a [ __ ] headache
and i want to be just like really dude
it's a kid man
what the [ __ ] are you doing
[ __ ] keep it a [ __ ] [ __ ] who says
that about a kid
huh
i'll tell you who a dodger fan oh i'm
already i'm already warming up the [ __ ]
talk for the world series if it happens
a dodger fan the kinds of fans that kick
a father to death in front of their kids
all right it's been said
how come they don't get more [ __ ] for
that jesus christ people bring up the
flake gate all the time we didn't kill
anybody
[Laughter]
um
now the west coast
someday they'll learn to just you know
stop it just [ __ ] talk and having fun
that nobody needs to get [ __ ] stabbed
um
all right now i'm gonna have all the
[ __ ] la people crying at me all right
that's kind of what happens nowadays um
so anyway the kid was totally cool
the whole time on the plane
and uh
until we started descending and then
like you know our ears are bugging her
so she was getting upset by that but she
was yelling so much i'm like she's
actually going to clear it out and i
think she did and then she was fine
and i was really happy for her i was
also really happy that nobody yelled at
the kid because i've seen that happen
i saw a guy do that on the red line one
time
the subway in boston
we were [ __ ] somewhere in near like
quincy on our way out to like you know
on the braintree line
and this guy got up
this woman's kid was crying he got and
it was only like five people on the
train
and he got up
walked over to this mother just by
herself a young mom with the kid
and said can you shut that kid up but
blah blah blah and i was sitting there
going like oh my god i can't believe
he's doing that right
but i didn't do anything
and then this woman this black woman got
up
and just [ __ ] laid into the guy go
what the hell is
it's a baby get out and sit down she go
damn
i sat down and then i just felt like the
biggest [ __ ] ever
that i didn't do anything
uh but i didn't oh freckles kept his
[ __ ] mouth shut
i was like i don't want to get into a
fight on this [ __ ] train
[Laughter]
i don't need that
this guy's going to yell at a baby and
then beat me up i don't [ __ ] well you
know just want to get to my [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] car
and get home um
so anyway oh another thing like there
wasn't enough traffic this is so funny
we go to leave and we go to go to the
airport
and there's a [ __ ] marathon i'm like
you gotta be [ __ ] me but fortunately
where we were at
all the people that were gonna run it
had already gone by so it was just sort
of the walkers and like the old people
you cannot [ __ ] believe the shape
that some people are in and they get
through a marathon
i was looking at some of them i'm like
oh my god
in my shape i wouldn't want to walk five
miles
i walk five miles in the bottom of my
feet you know
start getting like whatever you call
those things they start getting like uh
start peeling and [ __ ] like i can't
[ __ ] handle it i mean obviously i
guess you get a new
sneaker you get some [ __ ] inserts or
something like that but i was looking at
these people like god you know good for
you jesus christ
it was the [ __ ] you know it was the
hojo crowd
they were walking along
they'd run a little bit and then they
would walk
and then i saw like there was a clock
and it just said 20 miles to go
i was like [ __ ] me
has anybody ever done that i don't want
to talk to somebody oh if you ran one
let me know but also like
you're just out of shape right
and you just say i'm gonna [ __ ] do i
i'm just gonna do this
like i guess if you just keep you know
just keep going you can do it but oh my
god
you know
i've been really dedicated to a few
things in life but everything else i
never had a problem quitting it
and that would be one of them you know
what
i think i could run like half of it and
then i'll just walk
the rest of it and then what i would do
is i would run like maybe
two or three miles and then i would walk
maybe you know i would be like all right
i'm quitting at eight i'd quit at eight
miles
then i'd be in traction
oh my god if i walked [ __ ] eight
miles that would be the end of my week
and these [ __ ] people like i keep
thinking people are older than me and i
forget how old i am
you know because now i see people
because i've taken care of myself you
know i use lotion and [ __ ] but you know
if you didn't use lotion you just kept
[ __ ] eating cinnabon and [ __ ]
shotgun and beers by the time you're 53
years old man you you can look like a
[ __ ]
sea captain
[Laughter]
like some [ __ ] lobster fisherman man
like all [ __ ] weathered and [ __ ] i've
seen a few people while i'm just like
god damn i'm older than i got you by
five [ __ ] years
you know it makes me feel good about
myself because i'm vain but on the other
side i'm like you know this guy's really
actually showing me how old i am i'm
really not fooling anybody
just because i keep painting the house
i keep putting lotion on my face is what
i do like the [ __ ]
fighting irish they keep they paint
their helmets before every game
so they look special i think that that's
why they do it
so everybody knows that they're coming
or is that their nod
you know
they're wearing their sin on top of
their head
having gold helmets and they
spray paint the gold
before every game
reminding uh
all the parishioners of
the the gold that you know
was found
after world war ii that they had somehow
gotten from the nazis that were taken
from jews
isn't that what happened
can you imagine what what kind of side
deals was the vatican making
when that whole thing is going down
okay
and they're running this business now
who's can do the catholic church is
basically netflix before netflix it's
like netflix with religion
they went global
with that [ __ ]
and now they're sitting there
and all their customers are killing each
other right
and they're sitting in that sovereign
state
vatican city
now there's no [ __ ] way they weren't
talking to both sides
right that had to have been there was a
lot of that from what i heard
even on the allied side i've heard talks
about america doing it
[ __ ] england doing it there was a lot
that was a lot of chatter there's a lot
of chatter people trying to position
themselves let me see
catholic
church
position
in world
war
ii all right i wrote war w-o-a-r i don't
know why i write that like bore
world war ii here we go what do we got
here
all right
vatican records why do they always keep
records i don't understand that you're
doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] why do you write it
down
and why don't you just lie and say oh
you know
we were on the allied side pope pius xii
was silent during the holocaust
yeah i mean that would be like if one
streamer
you know against another streaming
company if they find out that
all the customers for their streaming
company were getting [ __ ] murdered
they would be like hey that's more
[ __ ]
less competition
so many layers to this especially if
you're dumb like me and you just plug in
your own theories without really reading
about now the vatican records may reveal
whether he collaborated
with the nazis well i think the fact
that he kept his [ __ ] mouth shut
i think he was sitting there at the very
least going like all right i don't know
who's gonna win but i want to survive
and this little sweaty guy with this
silly little mustache doesn't seem to be
mad at us yet
so why
start that okay this guy obviously does
not fear the afterlife considering what
he's doing
so
and he has tanks with [ __ ] porsche
engines in them uh we need okay it was a
saturday
shabbat what does that mean shabbat
shabbat ranks in october 1943 the nazis
have been occupying rome for a month
which is where the vatican is for other
morons out there like me an hour before
sunrise they surrounded the jewish
ghetto and began
la razia the roundup
evil bastards within a few hours more
than a thousand italian jews mostly
women and children heartless [ __ ]
bastard had been herded together a few
blocks from the walls of vatican city as
one why wouldn't they let them go into
the walls
why wouldn't they save themself
preservation as one nazi ambassador
later put it the jews were loaded into
trucks and taken away under the pope's
very windows
whether the pope witnessed the
deportation or not he said nothing
only 16 of those jews would survive
there you go
there you go i looked up one thing then
i read it
i didn't even read the whole thing
and now i will tell that story
until i eat too many trans fats and
forget it all right so
yeah there was a lot of uh there was a
lot of that
there was a lot of that
uh
you know or the other way to do it was
you remain neutral
like you know i don't want to get
involved in this i don't want to get
involved in this like sweden don't want
to get involved okay we're just you know
we're just
conscious uh consciously uh none of your
objectors we're just
just sort of watching this
watching it unfold do you know i've told
this story before that
sweden wasn't an economic power
at that time
before the war but after the war they
became an economic power for the fact
that they were just they were still
standing and their
city was functioning
uh
because everything else had been [ __ ]
laid to waste and one of the things that
they did was they looked the other way
when the nazis
came in
to sweden to go into norway
to uh
[Music]
take those guys over and they look the
other way and let them use their own
train system
and uh
if i remember correctly this is how the
swedes told me this
that norway
sweden had used to own the the lower
third of their country
in norway through whatever negotiations
or whatever they had finally gotten it
back
and then world war ii happened and
sweden let the nazis get on their trains
and go into norway and [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] [ __ ] up over there
and the war ends sweden's still standing
so there are massive economic power just
because their lights are still on norway
is in disarray and at one point they
actually tried to sell what they got
back back to sweden just to get out of
just to get the [ __ ] economy going in
sweden said no
you know really [ __ ] move said no but
then the irony of all ironies
is they discovered a bunch of oil i
don't know if it's in that part of the
land
and now norway has a ton of [ __ ]
money and this
swedish guy said yeah now we go into
norway and we do the jobs that
norwegians don't want to do how [ __ ]
funny is that
look at bill look at this look become a
little
more on history for you here all right
let me read the uh
the advertising here all right simply
safe everybody there's big news
from my favorite home security company
simply safe just launched their wireless
outdoor security camera that's right
jesus christ they're inside now they're
outside
time these guys are done they're gonna
have they're gonna [ __ ]
be able to film the burglar from his
hideout all the way to your house that's
right simply safe the system that u.s
news and world report names best home
security system of 2021 just got even
better this brand new outdoor security
camera is engineered with all the
advanced technology and security
features you want and need to help keep
you and your family safe it has an ultra
wide 140 degree field of view so you can
keep watch over your entire yard it has
a 100
1080p hd resolution whatever that means
sounds impressive with an eight-time
zoom
get all up in that guy's face see who
the [ __ ] he is
you don't see a lot of women burglars do
you
uh what means that means you can zoom in
it seems like women shoplift guys like
to break in
am i doing like 80s stand-up right now
with like you know breaking and entering
what's the deal with shoplifting ladies
love shoplifting guys are like oh i
don't want to do that
i want to break a window uh that means
you can zoom in and clearly see things
like faces and license plates to capture
critical evidence dude how psyched are
the cops here's his face here's his
license plate
just go down it's like postmate
he's gonna pick him up it has a built-in
spotlight with color night vision so you
can keep an eye on what's going on day
and night it's super simple to set up at
ease usually just takes minutes
and it has an easy to remove
rechargeable battery so it doesn't need
an outlet and can go anywhere on your
property this camera has it all and it
integrates with your simply save home
security system extending its protection
to the outside together it means every
door window and room are protected and
now your property will be too to learn
more
about the exciting new simply safe
wireless outdoor security camera visit
simplysafe.com
that's s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a
dot com
sorry slash burr what's more simply safe
is celebrating this new camera by
offering 20 off your entire new system
and your first month of monitoring
service free
when you're enrolling in interactive
monitoring again that's simplysafe.com
burr
all right oh policy genius
you know compared to pumpkin patch photo
shoots and costume planning shopping for
life insurance with policy genius can be
one of the the easiest tasks
on your october to-do list
why
why policy genius policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over a dozen
top insurers all in one place why
compare you could save fifty percent or
more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius you can save
thirteen hundred dollars or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
genius to compare policies the licensed
experts at policy genius work for you
not the insurance companies so you can
trust them to help that you navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process that kind of service has earned
policy genius thousands of five-star
reviews across trustpilot and google
an eligible applicant can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy has recently was recently rated
number one by forbes advisor higher than
options from ladder ethos and bestow
getting started is easy first head to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much life insurance coverage you
need and compare personalized quotes to
find your best price when you're ready
the policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and scheduling for free policy
genius doesn't add on extra fees head to
policygenius.com to get started right
now policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right oh
and lastly
but not leastly
stamps
dot com you've heard me talk about
stamps.com they've been sponsoring the
show for over nine years now and if you
haven't tried it
what the hell are you waiting for since
1998 stamps.com has been an
indispensable tool for nearly one
million businesses look at that 1998
almost the height of the dot-com
uh uh bubble
and they survived because they were
actually a legit company
as opposed to pets.com and all that [ __ ]
it's worth 5 million zillion dollars
stamps.com brings the service of the us
postal service and ups shipping right to
your computer whether you're in office
sending invoices a side hustle etsy shop
or a full-blown warehouse shipping out
orders stamps.com will make your life
easier all you need is a computer and a
standard printer no special supplies or
equipment within minutes you're up and
running printing official postage for
any letter any package anywhere you want
to send and you'll get exclusive
discounts on postage and shipping from
usps and ups cut the confusion out of
shipping with stamps.com
with stamp.com's new rate advisor tool
you can compare shipping rates and
timeless timelines to easily find the
best option there's no risk and with my
promo code burr you can get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage at a digital scale
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in burr that's stamps.com promo
code bur stamps.com never ever go to the
post office again
all right
all right now here we go
we're getting into the emails here i and
somebody tore me a [ __ ] new one
coming up some lady just thinks i'm the
[ __ ] worst person that ever lived
evidently
all right uh dial dying while living out
worst fears
hey billy red sack i love that one
that's like right to the [ __ ] point
hey billy red sack
uh i'm a few weeks behind but you've
asked for examples of people dying in
the midst
of living out their worst fears did i
ask for that
i have one of the worst
with a link to the news story too oh
jesus
oh jesus
there was a nurse who was prepping a
patient for an mri the patient was very
claustros
phobic so asked for a sedative to help
her relax
yeah those mris man
you know
i've had a couple of those i just
i always just say i can breathe and
there's nothing on my chest so it
doesn't bother me but i don't i don't
suffer like from claustrophobia like
you know you got to do like my older
brother used to sit on my chest and i
can't breathe you start freaking out i
hate that [ __ ] so i can't imagine people
that are claustrophobic going into those
things so anyway the doctor ordered
for said which is like a valium the
nurse couldn't find versed in the
medication dispenser probably because
that is a brand name
so she got
vacaronium instead
fecaronium is a medication used in
surgery to paralyze all the muscles of
the body
so the patient doesn't thrash around
while being operated on it also
paralyzes your muscles of breathing
which is why in surgery you have to have
a breathing tube put in oh my god
i asked you to send this in this is
[ __ ] horrific
only paralyzes your muscles it doesn't
sedate or knock you out so it is never
given alone as it would be a terrible
feeling to not be able to move speak or
breathe on your own but to be able to
feel everything happening
well that's what happened to the woman
in the mri oh my god she couldn't call
for help
she was already claustrophobic and then
when she slid into the narrow tube she
was given the drug to help her relax she
became fully paralyzed and couldn't call
out or squeeze the panic ball they give
you to signal for help
so she died of suffocation in a small
and close place helpless and fully
conscious until the end well
oh my god well how quick does the
medicine come on
i mean if she couldn't call out from
help in the very beginning maybe it came
on quickly
and if have you ever seen those ufc
members one time watching stevo get
choked out like he was out immediately i
hope for this person i'm not
claustrophobic but in terms of living
through your worst fears
and having the worst happen i think that
one takes the cake jesus christ
here's a story about it tennessean.com
jesus christ there's one for tennessee
get your mri in kentucky
or go south down to georgia uh lady
listener
oh this is the lady that just [ __ ]
rips me a new one rips me a new one
uh
and what i love about it is she already
like
she's so emotional and so mad
that right above she goes ladylistener
dash [ __ ] above your pay grade
you know so her ego's in check
dear bilbo t baggins
uh
wait is this the one no no no this isn't
the one is this the lady there was a
couple that ripped me this week
oh no i think this is the lady
wait a minute wait a minute
is this the one
wait a minute
where the [ __ ]
is this email it didn't come in
i don't have to edit this part out
because i'm just sitting here babbling
wondering where the [ __ ] it this thing
is no there was some woman giving me
[ __ ] about
saying stuff about the [ __ ]
pink stuff in the nfl where the hell's
that one
this other woman's just giving me [ __ ]
saying i'm unfuckable
like i didn't already know that it's
like you know
i go out in the world with his face i
you know
i went up to bat
with this hand that i was dealt
um
where's fears oh picture coming okay oh
here is okay okay okay
pink [ __ ] comic comment dear billy
clueless
i was incredibly surprised by your
ignorant comments about breast cancer
awareness events in the nfl during the
commercial read
of your mmp
well then you're obviously not a regular
listener i always
was talking about how they wore that
pink stuff and then that whole
that wasn't i'll wait to the end i'll
wait till the end about
talking about this [ __ ] first your
sexist comment
about it being the month of the lady
no that wasn't a cute thing month of the
lady
okay i'm sexist
i mean i am
according to other women so i guess
you're another woman say that completely
degrades women in general
how
if i say the month of june
is gay pride month does that degrade
gay people i guess because i said the
lady
what was i supposed to say the warriors
okay don't say you were just kidding you
weren't i can say whatever i want
what the [ __ ] why are you talking to me
like you're my parent
now don't say you you're just kidding
you weren't this is this is what it's
like to do stand-up now
how they took it is how you meant it and
you tell them i didn't mean it that way
you're lying
all right evidently you know what my
thoughts are okay this was evident by
your next dumb ass comment
wait a minute
my next dumbass my whole podcast is one
dumbass comment after another
why are you [ __ ] dying on this hill
you could have chose all of these other
well you could have got outside yourself
and had empathy for somebody else that
didn't suffer from something but no no
no not you but wait you're a better
person all right
this was evident by your next dumbass
comment
i kind of like this like because half
the times i forget what i said
saying what's up with all the pig [ __ ]
well i'm a comedian i mean that's how we
get into subjects
what's the deal with picture
now you have no idea what that moment is
about
oh i can explain that to you
yeah that whole cancer awareness and
holding that thing up i i believe it or
not
people are aware that there is cancer
and people are aware that people have
died of it do you know how many [ __ ]
friends in family i have lost to cancer
do you have any [ __ ] idea
all right if you were at a party i
wouldn't [ __ ] bring a sign and hold
the guy's [ __ ] name up in front of
you and ruin your [ __ ] party
you know i this is the the i watch
sports to escape that i do benefits all
the [ __ ] time for this [ __ ]
i meet the people i see them in the beds
[ __ ] withering away i saw my buddy
like that
yeah like i'm watching a football game
everything on facebook all of this [ __ ]
is all gloom and doom all the news is
gloom and doom the weather channel is
gloom and doom i have one oasis to watch
a bunch of people
have a ball and try to get it across the
[ __ ] goal line and people have to
bring up gloom and doom again that's
what i mean like why are you doing that
why are they doing that
anyway and if you knew anything about
the nfl which i don't think
you uh not that you don't know about
this sport like they have had a sort of
a like a
checkered
past when it comes up
comes to these types of things where it
looks like they're doing these things
and they're actually making a [ __ ] load
of money off of it
which i believe the first time they did
the pig thing
for what i read allegedly remember those
pink jerseys you'd buy and you think
wait am i you know
my aunt or uncle died of cancer i'm
gonna buy this pink jersey and this is
you know so nobody else has to go
through it evidently like half of one
percent of the money for the jersey
went to cancer and the rest of it went
to the nfl that's what i read
it's kind of like when they did the
support the troops thing and they were
cut to a troop sitting in the crowd you
thought oh look at them they're
patriotic and then you found out that
they when
whoever they were showing being a marine
or an or a
navy guy or whatever they charged that
branch of the service for a commercial
so
all right but whatever but uh you know
let's get back to her ripping me a near
new one it's about educating women about
a disease that kills far more women than
covid19
a virus you relentlessly talk about
well wait a minute now i'm offended
okay
are you saying that all of those people
i mean
how many people need to die
before i don't talk you're doing the
same thing to me
so not enough people died of covid
so you find me talking about it
relentless
all right i'll try to ease it up
uh early detection is vital to surviving
enter cancer really
oh there's some new information
everybody knows that
i got yet another colonoscopy i got
[ __ ] jacques cousteau going up my ass
here in another [ __ ] month but but
that you know i almost forgot that that
was that that was gonna camera was gonna
go up my ass
i i almost forgot but thank god that guy
had okay all right i just get it i get
it now i see your point
um as a person who has seen breast
cancer completely destroy families
well who hasn't
and could have been prevented with early
detection i applaud the nfl for trying
to make a difference okay now there
right there
your heart is in the right place
okay
you ever go out on a date
ma'am
and you date a gu you go on a date with
a guy
and you just think he's a dreamboat and
then after your date you're talking him
up to your friend and your friend just
has this look on her face or his face
and you're like what what's going on
yeah you know
you might not want to have a second date
with that guy that guy you know he's a
little shady
i'm sure he i'm sure he was nice i'm
sure he was polite i'm sure he held the
door that's what the nfl is
you just have to know that okay
um
i'll leave it at that and you can enjoy
yourself thinking that their heart is in
the right place their heart is at the
bank always
um if you if having quote the pink [ __ ]
on the field helps educate
and encourage women viewers on their sig
or their significant others to discuss
early detection and save lives
then yeah
it's worth your clueless ass being
annoyed by it
all right
okay i mean
look i've been watching the nfl and i've
seen what they've been doing for the
better part of a half a century
and uh you know okay
i mean these are the same people also
knew that the players were getting brain
damage and they they suppressed the
[ __ ] information
and now
they've settled out of court for these
like pathetic subs and now they're
[ __ ] with people's money and i'm
reading this thing that they
grade on a racial curve as far as
they're just using all these [ __ ]
flim-flam ways to try to get out of
paying it but i'm sure they're i'm sure
their heart's in the right place here
and i am a clueless idiot and i'm sexist
and i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and uh i shouldn't can relentlessly talk
about covid because not enough people
have died of that
and it hasn't led to yet another great
small business down the road going out
of business that's great yeah so i'll
shout them about that
um
anyways think of it this way if the
if the pink [ __ ] caused you and the
lovely nia to have a conversation
that leads to her being more aware of
the disease and how to prevent it you
should be thankful for the pink [ __ ] now
first of all like this is really
condescending how [ __ ] dumb do you
think i
am that i just sit there and i go i
don't know breast cancer exists and then
some pink [ __ ] sweatband goes by oh
wait a minute
i need to have a talk with my wife
anyway she goes i know this your
children will be thankful
that it may have saved your mom's life
jesus how hard is this person trying to
sell their point bringing my my family
right into it my wife gets checkups
okay i get checked for the ass cancer i
have people look at my heart i do all of
this [ __ ] because i've lost like three
friends to heart attacks i've lost
countless people to cancer
all right
okay and it's really sad
and i miss all of those people and it
would be nice to watch a football game
and not be reminded of it
it feels like more it should be on the
news
or a billboard sports are supposed to be
an escape
i feel that's just my own opinion and
i'm entitled to it and i can have that
okay without you coming at me and
calling me sexist
um
anyway and you're also really late to
the party because i did a bit about this
on a talk show one time and it [ __ ]
killed as far as i remember so anyway
all right well you know maybe someday i
can [ __ ] be as enlightened as you are
and set aside this pandemic
[Music]
okay
lady listener
[ __ ] above your pay grade oh [ __ ]
above your pay grade all right so now i
i read this in a different
contest this woman is talking about
banging somebody i guess better than you
are um
dear bilbo t baggins
um lady listener
now why would you say you're a lady
listener that is sexist and offensive to
women and i'd like to share a female
female perspective to help balance out
your podcast oh jesus well yeah i've
been asking you guys to write in
you know i mean granted i don't say
anything that makes you want to write it
other than tell me to go [ __ ] myself
like that pink lady did by the way this
is my favorite podcast so thanks for
your work on it no problem
anyways i often hear men complaining how
hard it is
to make
to make women like you
i think you miss something here
yeah you kind of missed something i
often hear men complain how hard it is
to make women like you what bang them
uh because the next sentence is that you
need to trick us into [ __ ] you i can
understand that it's hard to woo a woman
uh no you can't
unless you're a lesbian
unless you've actually had to hit on a
woman
to have sex
you have no [ __ ] idea i had this
conversation with my wife one time
she was telling me one time she goes you
know guys just say the dumbest [ __ ]
you know to you in a bar and blah blah i
said all right let's flip the tables
let's say i was controlling
i was in control of my desires and you
had to come over and wow me hit me with
an opening line she had nothing
and i was being a [ __ ] to her and she
goes you're just making this difficult
more difficult than it needs to i said
welcome to my world
anyway who is more attractive okay
i can understand that it's hard to a
woman who is more attractive than you
uh but if you try to [ __ ] someone as
ugly as you are i'm pretty sure they'll
say okay
um no that's not how it works
however a few men want to date a woman
who is
at their level physically and i respect
that preference
but let's flip the script and see if
that argument still holds water well i
mean first of all you're talking about
something you don't know anything about
which is hitting on women
and actually hitting on women who are
better looking than you is not a hard
thing it's a confidence thing
all right
and then the the ped way of getting a
better looking woman is to make a bunch
of [ __ ] money but that doesn't count
i'm talking you're sleeping on a futon
you're going in there
you like to moan you don't care if she
comes stays laser praise you got the
[ __ ] attitude right that [ __ ]
yeah i know some legends
legends
who are probably i mean at best
sixes
that are absolutely been crushing it for
decades
because they're confident
and they know and they just worked on
they worked on it the way you work on a
[ __ ] jump shot and they are [ __ ]
amazing at it
so i think a lot of men they don't want
to put the work in and they can't get
past it's like people doing stand-up the
reason a lot of people want to do it but
they never do it because they're so
worried about bombing and the pain of
that you have to push through that until
you're bulletproof you don't care
you don't care
who gives a [ __ ] you just move on to the
next show
um
that's what i would say but what do i
know i'm just a sexist guy so she goes
let's flip the script which is fair
because that's what i did with my wife
when i made her hit on me oh she bombed
oh she bumped
she's like hey how's it going i just
looked at her like
anyway but let's flip the script and see
if that argument still holds water i'm a
woman
uh do you think there's any way in hell
i can convince a guy who wasn't already
100 physically attracted me
to want to [ __ ] me
um i have no idea i'm not a woman let
alone date me
i have no idea it's way harder for women
to impress a man with anything other
than her looks
oh absolutely
absolutely i mean that's why you guys
walk in with half your [ __ ] who are
hanging out so you get some drinks
um
i assume that wasn't a joke you meant
that i assume your next point is
probably that um
i assume that your next point is that
i'm probably ugly
why would i say that
so that's why i'm saying this i wouldn't
say that it's just listen i'm a dick i'm
not [ __ ] mean at least i don't think
i am i'm not the most beautiful girl in
the world but i do get some attention
i'm cute enough to get by you sound like
a keeper to me
you know
you're not the most beautiful girl so
you know what that means you probably
got a great personality
and then you know not everybody's coming
up to you so when somebody does you
appreciate him
i mean that's you know
he did some hardy jesus christ they're
walking around like you know
i remember going on dates a few times
right a few times when i actually got a
beautiful woman to go on a date with me
before i met my wife not saying my wife
isn't beautiful all right but by then i
was in my 30s and i just didn't give a
[ __ ] so
that's when i started you know doing all
right but in my 20s
a couple of times i went out on dates
this one beautiful woman in particular
and the entire time i was in the
restaurant she was just looking around
to see who was looking at her
and i put it all on me going i'm not
holding your attention and blah blah
blah and then years later i was just
like
she couldn't help it
you know we were like 21 or something
like that
all of a sudden the whole world's paying
attention to her that must feel amazing
what's she gonna do look across the
table at me
uh so anyway she goes so i'll put it to
you and your lovely loudmouth wisdom is
there anything a woman can do to [ __ ]
or date outside of her lane
i've seen men do it frequently yeah we
do we usually do it one or two ways
you're either funny or you you
have a level of success
i've seen women do it less often
but how
i'd love to get your purse perspective
and also that of the lovely nia i gotta
have neo out of here it's just hard you
know she has to watch the kids when i
come out here
uh it would be even cooler if she agrees
with me on some of these points well i'm
not gonna debate any of your points
other than like hitting on women but
that other stuff i don't know what it's
like to be a woman um
thanks and go [ __ ] you [ __ ] yourself
[ __ ] perspective detective why don't
some other women write in about this i
would think um
universally speaking the hardest thing
is finding somebody that deserves your
love
you know what i mean
because i could give you an easy example
of something that will make a guy hang
around is if you cook for him
because no women do that because just
even suggesting that
is considered sexist when the reality is
cooking for somebody is one of the
nicest sweetest loving things
you could do for them now if they don't
appreciate it they're like where the
[ __ ] my [ __ ] club sandwich
yeah then you start
feeling like that but like uh i love
cooking for my wife i love cooking for
my family
and
because it's the way that i show that i
care about them so i would think
things like that
or uh
i don't know if you're into the same
type of [ __ ] if you're into sports if
you're into something where there's an
overlap or something like that or if
you're like funny or something like that
i'm just going by me you know my wife
was [ __ ] hilarious
um and she was just into this all of
this stuff
you know she's the one who got me into
steely dan
i'm [ __ ] in harlem with an
african-american woman and she's playing
me a steely dad album i was just like
who is this
how many layers is going and she just
was really interesting
so um
i don't know yeah so
you want to date a better looking guy
yeah why'd you want to date some [ __ ]
slob or some bald bastard like me i
would say yeah uh
i also think like if you if you do
activities which is hard during this
pandemic
you know i mean i always found like it
was way easier if everybody's supposed
to be there
that everybody kind of had their guard
down and you could kind of feel the vibe
of who somebody was
whereas you go into a bar and
everybody's kind of got their guard up
right the guys are on the prowl the
lady's like oh jesus look at this
[ __ ] creep over in the corner with
the chest hair right
those places are not good to meet people
but um
i got to be honest with you like
i can
only give you advice from the male
perspective so i imagine there's a bunch
of women rolling their eyes
but i can't tell you that uh
you know i don't know maybe i'll get nia
to come on here at some point
like how to do that um
because i don't know i'm not gonna
[ __ ] be a hypocrite here now act like
i know
what the [ __ ] you need i don't know i
don't know what you can do this got to
be a book on it right
that's why i don't understand about
insults there's books on how to get
women like why would you hang out with a
bunch of other people who aren't getting
[ __ ]
it's like i don't know how to fix a car
neither do i hey let's sit around and
talk about it
the car will never run
all right sugar in the house debate
hey
hey there billy uh birthday cake ticks i
know
i still got him
i'm a huge fan i just saw you at one of
your sold out shows at the fox theater
in st louis you [ __ ] nailed it and it
was a dream come true now down to
business
nice thank you for coming out to the
show you know i did that movie i stayed
right across the street at that hotel
uh recently i cut out all added sugars i
noticed i had a serious addiction and
decided i really needed a change i got a
baby girl uh the same age as your son i
want to make sure i'm around for her as
much as possible yeah nothing like kids
to get you to [ __ ] straighten up to
my problem in perspective i drank three
tall cans of arizona arnold palmer's
every day
anytime my girlfriend had sweets in the
house i always ate it all sometimes even
before she got a chance to have some i
had a hard time with self-control
oh yeah dude i've been there
i've been there i have a 600 pound
person inside of me i just
paid my wife brought home these
chocolate [ __ ] uh
croissants
and there was two of them sitting under
the little cake thing you know
one of those glass things stands you put
a cake on and i saw them
and not only did i think of eating one i
thought of taking both of them and
putting ice cream in the middle of it
making a [ __ ] sandwich
i just don't do it anyway
a person goes on to say i made it a rule
to keep out all sugar from the house
as well so i wouldn't give in to any
temptation within two months of simply
cutting sugar out of my diet i dropped
20 pounds wow no exercise or anything i
was really [ __ ] proud of myself after
a while a little while my lady
started bringing candies back into the
house yeah you're a couple of junkies
somebody's gonna go score some heroin
then you're gonna be back on the [ __ ]
junk
i asked her several times not to or at
least hide them in a spot where i'm
never in
at the uh
never at
in the house or where i can't get to
them at all
she kind of bit my head off saying well
you should have better self-control
uh there you go well that's nice um well
that is true i think putting sugar back
in the house is the equivalent of
stocking up the fridge with a recovering
alcoholic's favorite beer
months into the process
um
this is what you should have done when
she said well you should have had better
self-control you shouldn't have said
anything back and you should have just
walked out of the room
i'm just going for a walk
and then come back and then just
be chill and wait for her to bring it up
again
and then just be like all right can we
talk about this now
like adults
all right
like
i want to be around for my daughter why
are you getting mad about that
you got to come from that place but if
the discussion starts with well you
should have better self-control you
wrote like five exclamation points like
it's not you're not gonna work it out
i'm big on going for walks it's another
way to drop weight
just go for a walk you just walk out of
the room that's what i i try to do now
anyway the guy said i said that same
thing to her several times but she gets
mad and makes a big deal out of it going
as far as saying fine i guess
i just can't have anything i enjoy in
the house anymore yeah she's feeding no
matter how careful or nice i'll ask her
she'll always make it all about her
i've told her a ton of times that she
should respect my addiction but she
always gets pissed off and turns it into
a huge argument for some reason
well probably because you dropped the
weight and she doesn't have your
willpower yet
and uh you know
sometimes you know when you're in a
couple situation and they're
they're cool with the [ __ ]
dad bod or the the [ __ ] you know
little extra pounds you have as a woman
they can get like insecure if you start
losing weight and looking good they they
get you know [ __ ] is changing it makes
them feel like
you're gonna get rid of them like all
kinds of [ __ ] happens dude like dropping
20 pounds
like [ __ ] with the balance of your
relationship it's really weird
um anyways he says this [ __ ] really
pisses me off and i can tell mentally
i'm starting to break yeah because
she's able to go off on you and you have
to sit there and act like you're trying
to figure out which wire to cut so the
bomb doesn't go off um so you can you
settle the debate for us
should she respect that i have an
addiction and keep the sugar hidden
addiction to keep the sugar hidden or do
i just need to suck it up and have
better self-control
uh
p.s the east st louis woke bits were the
funniest jokes i've heard in my entire
life much love to you and your family um
oh he was in st louis not atlanta okay
um
well let me ask you this sir
if your wife had a sugar addiction
and she told you not to put any sugar in
the house and then you brought it in
after a couple of months
and then she said she was willing to let
you have it in there if you hit it
would you do that for her
if the answer is yes then i don't think
what you're doing is out of line
um
i also think you need
to have better self-control also like i
have booze in the house i don't drink
anymore
i gotta tell you after a while
i don't even see it anymore like my wife
told me i asked her where something was
she goes it's underneath the bar
and i was thinking literally like a bar
like a like a
like a
ballet bar or something what bar in the
kitchen what are you talking she goes
the bar
i was like oh oh yeah oh yeah
because i go in there and to me it's i
don't even see the booze just underneath
i know there's batteries
right
i got kids and their [ __ ] toys need a
bunch of batteries so
that's where i'm at so um
it's a little bit of both but you know i
don't think it's fair that she's
going off on you like that and you have
to sit there
you know especially when you're making a
choice
that's going to be better for everybody
that she should be acting like that i
don't think that's a very mature thing
for her to do
and uh yeah she needs to be more mature
about that and that's just something
that you know
i don't know
she'll either accept that if she's an
adult
or she won't or maybe she will in a few
weeks but like that my big question is
if you're asking for something that you
would willingly do
without a fight for the other person and
it's something you really need and it's
going to not only make your life better
but everybody else is i don't think
that's too big of an ask
uh
but i be considering she has such an
emotional response to it i think i would
ask her what what is going on because
there's something else going on
beyond that
you know
women are so funny how they always do
that i guess i can't have anything i
like ever again
yes that's it christmas is cancelled all
right prostitute or normal woman oh
jesus
hey bill i don't season my chicken
enough burr oh neil would love that i'm
going to be straight forward
and ask for your advice do you think i
should continue seeing this one
particular prostitute
or should i just start [ __ ] a regular
girl
is this a joke i feel like [ __ ] the
prostitute because i don't have to worry
about her getting pregnant
and the head is amazing
look at the drop off on intellect when
the second a guy writes it
although i'm scared of catching a
disease
i'm in my early 20s and lots of women
consider me attractive the issue is i
don't like dealing with people in
general it takes a lot for me to
actually go out of my way to speak to
people
i find even i find
it even harder to find a woman i want to
[ __ ] just because i find most of them
to be just plain boring
and you find the prostitute to be
exciting all right well i think you
maybe have some
issues you might need to talk
to somebody about uh
well i mean like i mean yeah you hang
out with the prostitute there's gonna be
a lot more drama um keep in mind i don't
want a relationship right now i just
want to clap cheeks
unfortunately even that comes with drama
although if i really like a girl i
wouldn't mind a relationship dude you
are not ready for a relationship
in any shape
or form should i continue to [ __ ] the
prostitute or should i stop being a
[ __ ] and be patient with these other
women
thanks for the advice and i wish my hair
looked as good as yours when i get older
all right he's obviously breaking my
balls um i don't think you should do
either i don't think you should continue
banging this prostitute i don't think
that you should uh
be in a relationship i think you should
maybe go to therapy and figure out
why uh you don't like being around
people
why you find um
going to a prostitute better than you
know why you find people boring and [ __ ]
like that uh i'd say you know
i don't know i don't want to superimpose
my [ __ ] on you but like i don't know
it seems like maybe a little depression
maybe a little abuse growing up i don't
know what the [ __ ] it is i'm not a
doctor so i would um
the best thing about your email is that
you're not
in a relationship with anybody um
so what i would do is i would maybe go
into therapy and try to figure out
why
you've ended up in this place
all right talk it out figure it out
figure yourself out
you feel like you're [ __ ] ready
go and be ready but don't like get into
a relationship just because that's what
everybody else is doing at your age
because you're just gonna break
somebody's heart
you know and god knows you know i would
also get tested to see if he you [ __ ]
didn't catch anything i would do all of
that you know
yeah all right that's it okay jesus
[ __ ] deep emails this week all right
that's it everybody that is the podcast
um
go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll check in on
you on thursday